it plays SNES games it's portable it
connects to a TV sound familiar the
hyper can Superboy SFC is essentially a
Nintendo switch from the 90s it's a
novel and streamlined way to play your
original NTSC and PAL SNES cartridges
anywhere but it does have shortcomings
which make this hulking handheld a less
than ideal way to play your old carts
this is an updated version of hyper
conceived eeeh Superboy s from back in
2012 but now we have a few new features
and the Super Famicom color scheme the
Superboy SFC is available now for a
hundred US dollars now let's get into
some of the technical details the
Superboy weighs a little over 2 pounds
and measures in and about 11 inches wide
eight inches tall with a cart loaded and
three inches deep compared to the
Nintendo switch this thing's a bit thick
it's also due to the fact that you need
to load physical cards on top of the
device pin perfect technology helps card
stay in place and keep games running
even if their device gets jostled around
however it's sometimes difficult to
wedge cartridges in there without
feeling like you're gonna break
something this is especially true for
Super Famicom carts since the casing
doesn't sit perfectly flush I was
reluctant to force a Japanese Super
Mario World cartridge in there but I got
it to work just be very careful the
controller layout in organics are fairly
decent considering the size and design
face buttons shoulder buttons and the
d-pad feel good to press if you have
smaller hands it might be a bit tough to
get them around the device though two
front-facing speakers provide adequate
audio quality despite a lack in bass the
wonderful soundtrack of Chrono Trigger
doesn't sound tinny you can also use
headphones or earbuds with a 3.5
millimeter port but a light buzz can be
heard in quieter moments another feature
to SNES controller ports for multiplayer
games and better TV playability if you
have the old game pads battery life is
quite impressive at about 10 hours from
a full charge I used it for about 5 to 6
hours in total and didn't have to charge
once using 75% brightness when you do
have to charge a superboy it's done
through a micro USB port on top here you
can also find the pal ntsc switch the
reset button the power switch and AV out
port along the bottom is a 3.5
millimeter audio jack the volume wheel
and brightness aspect ratio combo button
for brightness levels are offered and
the max level is good enough to you
outdoors if you hold that down for about
three seconds it changes the aspect
ratio now the Superboy SFC sports a 4.3
inch LCD screen displays both
traditional 4 by 3 aspect ratio and 16
by 9 widescreen I don't find the 16 by 9
particularly useful as it just stretches
the normal image it feels like wasted
screen space on top of that the actual
image quality isn't that great because
of its washed out colors and fuzzy
motion these issues are exacerbated when
hooking it up to a TV it's a real neat
feature throwing your SNES games onto
the big screen seamlessly like a switch
seems dope but the amount of ghosting
you get is a deal-breaker for any game
that moves somewhat fast like Super
Mario World even in a turn-based RPG
like Chrono Trigger navigating the world
just doesn't look right when the image
looks so fuzzy in motion you should note
that the super boy only connects to an
external display through the package
composite cables plenty of modern TVs
still have those red white and yellow
inputs but it limits the visual quality
input lag is also something to consider
if you're gonna play on the TV
since the Superboy display still runs
while connected to a TV you can
immediately see a side-by-side of the
noticeable input delay when jumping
between the analog super Antti and the
Superboy it's clear how high perkins
offering isn't the best way to play
these games due to shortcomings in both
response time and color reproduction
despite all the compromises made in the
Superboy SFC there was something special
about playing these old cartridges on a
handheld sure it's bulky and I might be
awkward to have large and probably
valuable carts sticking out of the back
of a portable device but I had a ton of
fun kicking my feet up on the couch and
giving an earnest playthrough of some of
my favorite SNES games just don't expect
the highest quality visuals or a viable
way to play on TVs
[Music]